in Kenya's Masai heartlands living
conditions are harsh the traditional
maneater mud huts are modest homes with
no electricity or sanitary facilities
Olimpia Kip Leggett has plans to upgrade
them the echo monitor was born out of
necessity we can see for the old
monitors they are quite the rendering
they use it needs to be repaired quite a
bit with the cow dung it's also very
dark inside and not very well lit and
there's a lot of smoke coming out from
the house so there's a lot of diseases
associated with the old monitor so we're
trying to improve that and still
maintain the original authorship of
their monitors cow dung mixed with mud
is not a very durable building material
the old maniatis need constant
maintenance mainly done by women the
poor hygiene standards attract flies
that cause disease in children and
cooking with firewood is unhealthy and
unsustainable life before in a
traditional Monyetta was very hard
because the women have to get up very
early to collect firewood to prepare
breakfast for their children and when
the children have set off to school then
they embark on repairing the house where
it needs to be repaired
which means being back into the forest
to collect twigs and they mix the chicks
together with dung and mud tube 2 to
cluster the houses Olimpia has come up
with a new type of man yatta equipped
with solar cells and a rainwater tank
trips to nearby rivers to fetch water
are becoming less frequent women and
children have more time now they don't
need to collect firewood for cooking
anymore either
now their source of cooking heat is cow
dung which is first mixed with water and
stored
as it decomposes the dung produces
methane gas free biogas to burn the down
from the house which are kept within the
homestead there's a collection point so
it's collected and you don't need that
very much for our daily use for the
kitchen in this case because it's a
single home family home and then the
same is fed into the system and there's
a pipe connected to the homestead and
it's used for cooking cooking with
biogas has made life much easier and
healthier for Joyce Moran girl and her
family she convinced her husband to move
into an eco man yata two years ago for
him the step into a modernized world was
not easy today he only sees its benefits
in my house there's light in the kitchen
and also the food can be cooked quickly
compared to firewood the food's ready in
20 or 30 minutes so I've really
benefited from an eco Monyetta
I hope a lot of it common yet as I built
because it preserves the forest the soil
erosion because the trees weren't
waiting I got this solar-powered lamp
changed the mehrangarh all family's
daily routine previously they were
reliant on paraffin lamps which are
expensive and emit unhealthy fumes today
the fumes are gone and that can save up
money for food and their children's
education yes well enough they didn't
say the solar lamp has helped me a lot
before my children couldn't study at
night we used a paraffin lamp and when
the wind came it would put out the
lights
not someone else I see now my children
are doing well because they study at
night they've seen change
the local school also has solar power
now but most of the children don't have
electricity at home so they go to the
Murong Garros ecoman yata to do their
homework together under electric light
the impact has been very good people
have accepted them another very well as
such am seeing the benefits especially
with the monitor has already been put up
have seen the benefits in terms of
health in terms of the environment and
also we also have a better livelihood
for the people who have to now use the
new manner monitor the biggest challenge
is the cost not many families here have
five to ten thousand dollars to spend
like the Moon and arrows the hope is
that new funding subsidies and
continuous innovation will change that
[Music]